a
[Música]
bienvenidos a corresponsables la guerra
en ucrania ha entrado oficialmente en su
tercer mes más de 5 millones de personas
han huido del país en calidad de
refugiados y según un alto mando de las
fuerzas militares rusas que fue citado
por medios locales el objetivo de esta
segunda fase de la guerra sería tomar el
total control tanto del este como del
sur de ucrania en las localidades que ya
están bajo el control de las tropas de
moscú a los residentes se les están
entregando pasaportes y en las escuelas
y en diversas instituciones avanza una
verdadera política de rusificación de
qué se trata nosotros cuentan nuestros
colegas de fondo y carolyn danbolin
los daños se extienden por cientos de
metros en bueno baja una ciudad que fue
tomada por tropas rusas y separatistas
hace un mes y medio el 70% de los
edificios han sido destruidos al menos
parcialmente por las bombas en el patio
de esta escuela los proyectiles dejaron
cráteres en el suelo los cristales de
varias ventanas están destrozados y sin
embargo la escuela ha abierto esta es la
única hoy vamos a centrarnos en varias
zonas naturales y sus nombres en rusia
la política de rusificación comienza en
las escuelas las clases se imparten
ahora en ruso y aunque muchos alumnos de
esta escuela hablan ruso en casa algunos
siguen diciendo que el cambio ha sido
difícil
para la geometría las palabras son
diferentes totalmente diferentes
asociadas
tienes que aprender todo desde cero en
ruso es difícil
ah
en el coro del barrio cercano los niños
practican canciones rusas patriótica se
ensayan para el día de la victoria que
se celebra el 9 de mayo en rusia y
conmemora el final de la segunda guerra
mundial
[Música]
la bandera rusa donde ahora sobre el
ayuntamiento que aún conserva las
huellas del reciente conflicto algunos
residentes dicen estar contentos con la
toma de posesión rusa
rusia es rusia es nuestra hermana es
nuestra madre turca
otros en cambio prefieren no hacer
comentarios
es difícil no les 6 en el mercado y en
las tiendas la moneda ucraniana sigue
siendo aceptada pero los rublos están
cada vez más en circulación mientras la
ciudad lucha por recuperarse algunos
miran a rusia para que les ayuden en la
reconstrucción
si estamos con rusia espero que nos
ayude a reconstruir todo porque no lo
conseguiremos solos la versión rusa es
que han liberado a bueno baja y otras
zonas ahora son parte de la
autoproclamada república popular de
donges
nuestro inicio de la invasión rusa el
pasado 24 de febrero ya prácticamente no
quedan medios independientes en rusia y
los periodistas que deciden continuar
con sus labores se enfrentan a graves
riesgos el estado ruso ha endurecido la
legislación para castigar a todo aquel
que difunda lo que se ha considerado
como noticias falsas estableciendo una
verdadera censura de guerra quienes son
los que se quedan y cómo trabajan nos lo
cuenta él en amoroso
basili polonsky trabajó durante seis
años en el canal de televisión web
independiente 2 hoy empuja en la puerta
de un estudio del que sólo quedan ruinas
esta era nuestra sala de prensa de
internet que me gustaba mucho aquí está
la fila de estaciones de edición de
vídeos
y aquí frente a este puesto estaba
administración de trabajo esto el 3 de
marzo vasili presentó en directo el
programa de despedida de la cadena
después casi toda la redacción abandonó
rusia una hemorragia ya que la censura
de guerra se impone personas sobre
este es nuestro momento el momento de
las noticias calientes cuando ocurren
los eventos a cubrir deberíamos estar
trabajando como nunca y en cambio esto
es todo
vasili publica ahora sus informes en
youtube amenazado de cierre después de
dos trabajo durante una semana en el
periódico independiente de nóvaya gazeta
que también fue cerrado un caso como el
de green habló jean que llevaba 16 años
trabajando para la emisora de radio eco
de moscú y terminó cerrada el periodismo
ya no existe nuestra profesión ya no
existe que será de los graduados de las
facultades de periodismo no lo sé al
igual que basile irina se ha convertido
en blogger a su último texto una
investigación sobre la propaganda de los
medios de comunicación estatales
hemos recibido un memorándum interno que
indica los medios de comunicación del
grupo news media como deben tratar
distintos temas empezar diciendo que
ucrania quiere la guerra y bombardea su
propia población y terminar diciendo que
todo es culpa de occidente si intentas
desviarse de estas notas internas y no
seguir la línea oficial de información
que te imponen te arriesgas a 15 años de
cárcel
te conviertes en un enemigo al igual que
basile irina es una de las últimas
periodistas independientes que trabajan
en rusia y como él sabe lo que arriesga
a medida que la batalla por el este de
ucrania se intensifica en la religión
empieza también a jugar un rol muy
importante en el frente de batalla los
capellanes militares están al lado de
los soldados para ayudarles a mantener
la moral tal y como nuestro cuenta del
equipo de france 24 en kiev robert
parsons firme abuso y tajani
en una base militar de kiev el padre
andrew capellán del ejército ucraniano
dirige un servicio para los soldados la
iglesia está repleta muchos de los
presentes están a punto de partir hacia
el este hacia el donbass donde las
tropas rusas se están concentrando para
una nueva ofensiva
la iglesia es uno de los pocos lugares
en los que se puede acudir para obtener
calma espiritual y encontrar ayuda
extrema en cuanto al padre andrew gloria
a ucrania gloria a nuestros héroes y la
ayuda a todos los que acuden a él
[Música]
intento dar energía positiva a los
soldados y un sentimiento de felicidad
dios siempre me muestra que decir y qué
hacer
en este domingo de ramos ortodoxo está
allí para compartir una sonrisa con los
soldados y bendecirlos antes de que
partan para unirse a la batalla en el
este la iglesia está apoyando el
esfuerzo de la guerra de otras maneras
también recogiendo alimentos ropas y
medicamentos para la tropa
él es médico de las fuerzas aéreas
ucranianas
y venimos todos los días a buscar
medicinas para nuestros soldados para
ayudarles a reponerse así como a recibir
tratamientos de primeros auxilios
la fe sin acción no vale nada arriba
tenemos fe y abajo lo que hacemos es
actuar a diario los hechos importan
el padre andrew está en psicólogo como
sacerdote y aún más cuando parte hacia
el frente para estar con los soldados en
su momento de mayor necesidad a veces
los soldados se acercan a mí y me
preguntan dónde está mi arma yo saco mi
cruz y les digo esta es mi arma
una de las ironías de esta guerra es que
vladimir putin ha consolidado al pueblo
ucraniano como nunca antes
rusoparlantes y ucrania los creyentes
ortodoxos protestantes católicos y
musulmanes están unidos por la
determinación de controlar su propio
destino pero primero tienen una batalla
que ganar en el donbass
el show en ambas y hablando de cultura
volvió la bienal de venecia uno de los
escaparates más grandes del mundo
dedicado al arte moderno este año
marcado por la guerra en ucrania uno de
los artistas más esperados fue pablo
marco quien oyó de jarquín 3 el inicio
de lo conciba rusa la historia nos la
traen nuestros corresponsales natalie
mendoza y simone bauducco
la serenísima ahora el epicentro mundial
de la cultura y con razón la bienal de
venecia la gran congregación de arte
contemporáneo acaba de abrir sus puertas
este año uno de los artistas más
esperados es para froome a kof vivían
jarquín ucrania cuando comenzó la guerra
no quería dejar jarquín pero con los
bombardeos todo quedó destruido
completamente devastado cogí a mi madre
de 92 años y a mi mujer y huimos porque
me dije que no podíamos quedarnos más
tiempo ni siquiera puedo luchar allí
pero ahora puedo ayudar organizamos
subastas benéficas para vender arte y
enviar dinero allí a los voluntarios y
al ejército
aquí está su obra llamada fuente de
agotamiento una instalación con 78
embudos de bronce
el trabajo fue ex filtrado desde ucrania
tras el inicio de los bombardeos
[Música]
necesarias para elegir las sociedades
especialmente las del mundo democrático
están al límite no están dispuestas a
proteger los ideales y principios en los
que se basa la vida y esta fuente habla
de lluís
en los jardines de la bienal un segundo
espacio organizado por la delegación
ucraniana expone obras creadas tras el
inicio de la ofensiva rusa el objetivo
era afirmar la independencia cultural de
ucrania
estamos aquí para representar a nuestro
país nuestra identidad y nuestra cultura
lo que está ocurriendo en ucrania es
también una guerra de dos culturas la
cultura ucraniana está siendo
literalmente demolida por misiles rusos
pero también por la narrativa rusa y
nosotros estamos aquí para luchar contra
esta narrativa no muy lejos de allí el
pabellón ruso permaneció cerrado este
año
el pabellón ruso está cerrado porque los
artistas y el conservador se han
retirado y el comisario del pabellón ha
decidido dejarlo cerrado
en las redes sociales los artistas rusos
que iban a participar dijeron no hay
lugar para el arte cuando los civiles se
están muriendo
la bienal permanecerá abierta al público
hasta el 27 de noviembre
[Música]
en irak el bloqueo político es total
seis meses después de las elecciones
legislativas el país aún no ha decidido
a su presidente y primer ministro para
ello tendrían que reunirse dos tercios
del parlamento pero desde principios de
año no se ha alcanzado el quórum esto se
debe a que uno de los dos grandes
bloques políticos se niega a compartir
el poder mientras que el otro tiene
suficientes diputados para bloquear las
sesiones parlamentarias con
consecuencias palpables para la
población ampliamos con el siguiente
informe de luís silva zamora
en las afueras de bagdad muhannad al
azar y supervisa la construcción de
nuevas carreteras
normalmente este gestor de proyectos
dirige una docena de obras similares
pero debido al estancamiento político la
mayoría de ellos están paralizados la
mayoría era proyectos de infraestructura
como carreteras
alcantarillado electricidad etcétera se
financian con el presupuesto del estado
como aún no se ha formado el gobierno el
presupuesto no se ha presentado ni
aprobado se necesita mucho tiempo para
formar un gobierno en irak cinco meses y
medio de media el tiempo que toman las
negociaciones entre los dos bloques
políticos pero por primera vez en 20
años estas conversaciones simplemente no
se llevan a cabo porque el gran ganador
de las elecciones moqtada sádr no quiere
compartir el poder y se niega a
consultar a sus oponentes los partidos
cercanos a irán a los que pertenece está
diputada desde 2003 la gobernanza se
basa en el consenso todos los
componentes de la sociedad deben estar
de acuerdo entre ellos ahora quieren
romper con esta tradición eso está bien
pero tenemos derecho a formar una
alianza boicotear en las sesiones
parlamentarias ninguno de estos dos
bloques políticos tiene mayoría absoluta
el resultado es que el país está ahora
en un punto muerto y la población está
sufriendo en particular en los barrios
empobrecidos donde los habitantes suelen
vivir a la espera de proyectos que
supuestamente van a mejorar sus
condiciones de vida
[Música]
durante las elecciones se nos prometió
que los proyectos se pondrían en marcha
en cuanto se formará el gobierno por
ejemplo nos dijeron que se dejarían de
todo este basural para que pudiéramos
vivir normalmente aquí si supieras los
enfermos que estamos por el olor y el
humo
no hay garantía de que estas promesas se
cumplan pero hasta que se forme el
gobierno la esperanza de una vida mejor
también está paralizada en el país
gracias por seguir una nueva emisión de
corresponsables hoy desde la feria
internacional del libro de la ciudad de
bogotá nos damos cita la próxima semana
seca con más información en france 24 en
france 24 punto com